hello everybody and welcome to our may
charity livestream for the American
Cancer Society where we are raising
money to raise awareness for cancer
research and all that good stuff so
please click the link in the description
to go to the twitch channel where we are
currently live-streaming we will be
playing all sorts of games minecraft
left4dead
guns of Icarus Borderlands 2 and a few
other ones and we've actually got some
professional sound equipment here so
that it should be a more entertaining
show for you guys all professional and
whatnot right word right so hopefully
you'll be able to join us soon and
please donate whatever you can thank you
guys so much for supporting our efforts
and we will see you